[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi à 30 avril
des années 30 à nos jours le musée de la
ville donne la part belle aux objets de
notre intérieur pour notre nouvelle
exposition le titre extrait près de 90
objets de sa collection
pour ses 20 ans l'harmonie de saint
quentin en yvelines organise un festival
quatre formations du territoire étroit
franciliennes ont répondu présent pour
trois jours autour de thèmes musicaux
variés et c'est un trésor bien gardé par
sa commune or selon possède au sein de
son église
un tableau d'un peintre célèbre j'aime
delacroix et nous recevrons aussi
nathalie coup ni l'auteur yvelinoise
publie un nouvel ouvrage d'une rencontre
entre nietzsche est une artiste peintre
à la sortie de la seconde guerre
mondiale émerge une société de
consommation avec une intense production
d'objets diversifiée des objets qui
prennent place dans notre vie
quotidienne et qui ont inspiré les
équipes du musée de la ville de 50 ans
de vie sujet réalisé avec calypso vanier
du thermomix des années 70
robot de cuisine de 2015 l'histoire de
nos objets au musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines
il règne comme une atmosphère de
madeleine de proust 1 2 les objets
emblématiques sens veut que tout le
monde connaît c'est la petite
balance terraillon on a ce petit
ce petit appareil qui en fait assez
innovant en matière de balance de
cuisine puisque l'ensemble du mécanisme
est cachée pour être enfermé dans une
boîte très design est très
très organique comme ça très très simple
avec les angles arrondis pour sa
nouvelle exposition le musée nous
entraîne dans l'histoire des objets de
notre temps une exposition penser de
manière thématique autour des tanks qui
rythment en foyer 7,4 à thématiques sont
l'espace de la cuisine l'hygiène les
nouvelles technologies et le confort et
à travers c'est
donc ces quatre entrées on propose une
série d'objets assez assez divers et qui
qui rendent compte en fait de la manière
dont l'espace domestique donc
l'habitation s'est progressivement dotés
d'un daim
collection d'objets et donc des objets
avec une valeur d'usagé des usages mais
aussi du design la collection vous
mènent des années 30 aux années 2010
avec une période plus présente que les
autres les années 70 on voit arriver une
explosion de couleurs et de formes pour
en découvrir un peu plus sur certains
objets le musée de la ville propose des
visites flash des visites éclair
organisés de 13h à 13h30 la prochaine
c'est ce jeudi 2 mai il s'agira de la
machine à laver connor elle vous dévoile
ses secrets
une machine à laver qui révolutionne le
ménage domestique au cours du 20e siècle
vous connaissez le célèbre peintre
eugène delacroix mais vous ne saviez
peut-être pas que sa toute première
commande a été passée est réalisé dans
les yvelines
ce tableau est aujourd'hui un orcemont
il fait la fierté de la commune et de
son millier d'habitants marylène
iapichino vous raconte l'histoire
orcemont commune qui vient tout juste de
dépasser les 1000 habitants réserve une
surprise d'envergure dans son église
sainte trope se cache un trésor dont
seul le maire peut nous donner l'accès
[Musique]
ah bin là il est sous alarme oui tout
est barricadé sous alarme le tableau
lui-même et sous alarme le bâtiment est
sous alarme un tableau pas en 1819
commandé par un habitant est offert
depuis à la commune on arrive dans
l'église
et vous avez en face le tableau d'eugène
la grande la vierge des oiseaux
l'installer à gauche de l'autel
dans son retable sur mesure la vierge
des moissons du même peintre que la
liberté guidant le peuple livrent tous
ses secrets
on peut manifestement ce se dire que
c'est quelque chose qu'il a réalisées
après la moisson puisqu'on voit des
gerbes au pied de la vierge et de
l'enfant liés à la pignada la pléiade
c'était une manière à cette époque-là de
lier les bottes le blé dans la sacristie
de l'église
on trouve même une boîte digne de
l'oeuvre d'art et bien en fait c'est son
sarcophage qui a été fait sur mesure et
donc le tableau est déposée de son
retard lorsqu'il part à l'étranger
il est installé dans un dans son
sarcophage là et il sert sa soeur bien
sûr pour le transporter là où il sera
exposé ce qui a été fait d'ailleurs
récemment en 2004 au japon
je les ai emmenés là-bas le tableau
voyage et fait voyager le maire de la
commune où tout a commencé
c'est ici à la ferme du racine et que le
jeune peintre encore étudiant aux
beaux-arts reçoit sa toute première
commande
il est arrivé ici je ne la crois pour se
reposer tant donné qu'il était qu'il
était souffrant et donc il s'est
installé là aux racines est dans cette
ferme pour sûr pour s'y reposer ses lacs
donc monsieur bouffier cultivateurs
propriétaires terriens
j'ai donc passé cette commande un
tableau acheté 15 francs dont le paysage
s'inspire directement des alentours de
la ferme alors naturellement dans la
mairie on le retrouve partout reconnu
trésor national
il est parfois amené à s'exposer ça plus
lointaines destinations remonte à 2004
au japon pour une exposition sur victor
hugo et le romantisme
j'étais surpris à chaque fois j'étais
toujours surpris de voir l'importance
qu'ils portaient à ce tableau 1
ne serait-ce que sur les affiches et
puis même même dans le
dans la salle d'exposition où il était
exposé on rentrait sur la gauche il
avait sa petite salle à lui tout seul
dans le fond il était vraiment une mise
en valeur mais redore ce monde depuis 18
ans bernard bourgeois s'improvise
conservateur de cette oeuvre d'art et
même guide quand des visites sont
demandés mais fierté pour le maire et
son village pour ses 20 ans à roanne et
saint quentin voit les choses en grand
l'ensemble organise du 10 au 12 mai son
premier festival d'harmonie trois jours
de musique sur les territoires de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et on en parle
avec nos invités tous trois membres de
l' orchestre organisateurs roland simon
jules brunel et jean françois roubaud
bonjour à tous les trois jours roland
simon j'ai parlé d'un anniversaire celui
de la formation mais déjà comment vous
est venue l'idée de ce festival
alors ce festival disons que je l'avais
un petit plus des gens mémoire depuis un
certain temps et je tendais une bonne
occasion
l'année dernière on a fait un concours
et puis cette année pour les 20 ans a
dit me suis dit refaire quelque chose de
plus grand et qui permettent d'avoir
beaucoup plus de monde et donc j'ai
décidé de avait l'accord bien sûr de
tout le bureau de l'harmonie de monter
un festival d'harmonie et c'était l'idée
aussi parce qu'il ya d'autres harmonies
sur le territoire cette élaboration sur
la sur saint quentin en yvelines il ya
quatre harmonies et à l'harmonie de
magny les hameaux
ensuite il ya deux autres harmonies qui
sont attachés à des conservateurs
notamment maurepas et monty
donc ça fait au total quatre harmonies
dont quatre harmonies paix après comme
l'a fait ça sur deux journées ce n'est
pas suffisant donc on va essayer
d'inviter des harmonies extérieur à
l'agglo et donc nous avons cette année
blamont lit du conservatoire de suresnes
et l'harmonie alors c'est grand paris
oise seine seine et oise qui en fait
l'ancienne départementale qui allemand
nous a fait l'honneur de participer à
notre premier festival comme quoi ces
déformations qu'on trouve un petit peu
partout jean françois rollin justement
avant de parler des thèmes musicaux
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler ce qu'est un
orchestre d'harmonie bien orgueilleux
harmonie et un orchestre composé
d'instruments à vent accompagné par des
percussions contrairement à l'or qu'elle
symphonique où il ya des cordes et c'est
une formation qui permet de jouer
beaucoup de styles différents y compris
par exemple de la musique classique et
où les ça va être les bois par exemple
les clarinettes qui vont faire ce que je
faisais des cordes
voilà ça sous-entend d'une réadaptation
de certains morceaux de tout à fait y
ait beaucoup de morceaux qui sont
réécrit pour harmonie d'une
orchestration et puis il ya des oeuvres
originales et ça permet de faire des
choses assez varié et que le nombre de
musiciens je crois qu'au tout début de
l'harmonie de veiller vers 12-13 aimant
les petits ou aujourd'hui nous arrivons
à peu près une petite cinquantaine donc
ça permet de faire des choses vraiment
beaucoup plus intéressant tout ce qui
est conséquent
alors le festival et débute le 10 mai
avec lui cette fois un orchestre
professionnel
oui celui de la garde républicaine oui
les choses en grand
alors pour la première ford a décidé de
faire quelque chose de sympathique et
d'attrayant et donc j'ai contacté la
dernière l'harmonie de la garde
républicaine
ce qui a été un peu compliqué pour
trouver une date parce que c'est une
information très hâtivement prise est
très sollicité ne serait ce que par le
gouvernement depuis toutes les instances
de l'état mais également par des des
particuliers d organisation particulière
comme nous et donc c'est un peu
compliqué mais nous sommes arrivés à
trouver un accord qui est donc le 10 mai
et donc qui nous font l'honneur même je
dirais un grand honneur d'ouvrir ce
premier festival d'harmonie sur le
territoire de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines puis ses
conséquences que vous parlez vous êtes
50e ils sont 120 musiciens ça va
peut-être aussi donné
cd la garde républicaine la plusieurs
orchestres et le notamment d'orchestre
symphonique n'orchestre bison fanfare
lors qu'est ce que l'on voit à cheval
notamment pour le 14 juillet et puis un
orchestre d'harmonie et leur quête
d'harmonie qui viendra donc faire un
somme sa prestation sera composée de
soixante trois musiciens chefs compris
ce qui est relativement conséquents pour
une ce qui peut vous donner aussi des
petites rides et d'adaptation alors je
le disais tout à l'heure il va y avoir
plusieurs styles musicaux alger brunel
il va ailleurs du jazz du classique de
musique de films de la variété ça
signifie qu'on peut tout jouer
ce n'est pas parce que nous sommes une
harmonie qu'on va nous cataloguer à
jouer du beethoven du mozart et d'autres
morceaux classiques on peut adapter des
morceaux assez moderne
il ya par exemple montigny qui va jouer
du guns n' roses et oublie pharrell
williams
ils vont ensuite s'essayer sur des
musiques de films
il ya une harmonie de magny les hameaux
qui va essentiellement faire du sinatra
et les gens dit pas plus sur les
morceaux que nous allons jouer parce
qu'il faut garder un petit peu plus de
surprises pour le public mais justement
de jouer de tous les styles et ça permet
aussi d'attirer de dire à d'autres
musiciens venez vous avez cette
passion-là venez jouer avec nous oui
cela n'empêche pas de à d'autres
musiciens de venir chez nous ou si il ya
le montrera pertes war qui les a touchés
en particulier sur certains morceaux
qu'ils viennent nous revenir nous
rejoindre à l'harmonie de saint quentin
ou 6 ou sinon d'autres harmonies qui les
ont un peu plus touchés alors je voulais
qu'il y ait des surprises jean françois
robin est ce que vous répétez depuis
longtemps vous pour votre partie de
concert sur ce festival
bien sûr on répète nous ne sommes pas
des professionnels donc nous répétons de
façon détendue mais rigoureuse
effectivement et le cto de l'intérêt de
l'harmonie il faut répéter sa partie
individuelle mais c'est surtout de
l'ensemble écouter les autres et c'est
ça aussi qui est très intéressant
écouter les autres et puis pour pouvoir
donner quelque chose d'intéressant au
public et partager ces de partage de
musique donc voilà ce qui est
intéressant
oui nous répétons et nous sommes au
point ces mini jeux vous resterez pas il
était encore quelques jours pour tout
finaliser mais entre sous ses concerts
il y aussi des animations et elles
seront faites par les cuivres de
montblanc vous avez associés alors les
que les meneurs oui en fait quelques
mots là c'est un ce sont les cuivres en
fête qui qui joue avec l'orchestré
symphonique qui est associé alphonse
daudet le théâtre qu'ils ont besoin de
taxi qui nous reçoit et qui nous qui
nous prêtent tous les toute
l'infrastructure qui va bien et donc
l'équipe de mongolie où ils sont ce sont
les cuivres de ce qu'est symphonique et
qui est dirigé son 3 7 ou 8
c'est presque semi-professionnels déjà
ce niveau là et ils seront dirigés par
jean loup
pas dire j'en lis tout court on
découvrira beau c'est très sympa de leur
part
ça va nous permettre en fait d'avoir de
la musique qui n'a interrompu pendant
les trois heures puisqu'ils vont jouer à
chaque fois que l'iran changement de
plateau voilà accueillir un prêt pour
accueillir est avec moi éviter d'être ou
d'attentes
voilà merci à tous les trois lors je le
rappelle la première édition du fesman
ya 50 ans est le nom officiel débute le
10 mai prochain au théâtre
alphonse daudet de deux poignards un mot
d'humour à présent ces soirées ont
rythmé à la saison du prix ce modèle en
cours et 2 tv 78 samedi 4 mai prochain
vous pourrez découvrir la dernière
soirée du 7 8
humour pour vous donner un avant-goût un
extrait du passage d'un des artistes
alexis rossignol lille et humoriste mais
aussi chroniqueur sur france inter roma
chris pine et hautmont pêche
moi je viens des deux sèvres je passe ça
vous parle les deux sèvres
ouais c'est un petit département bon si
vous connaissez pas c'est normal c'est
c'est entre la vienne et la vendée et en
général quand tu as besoin de donner le
nom des départements limitrophes pour
que les gens si tu ton département c'est
la merde tu vois et quand les
départements limitrophes c'est la vienne
et la vendée ça pue du cul
mais moi j'ai pour habitude de dire que
si vous voulez les deux siècles c'est un
peu comme le point g c'est à dire que
tout le monde en a entendu parler mais
personne ne sait vraiment où sept succès
et en général quand tu trouves tu es
reste pas longtemps ça fait surtout
plaisir à la personne qui te reçois
[Applaudissements]
mais si vous laissez le genre de
départements où les parisiens vont se
ressourcer parce que les parisiens là
quand il ya un pont et ceux vivant à la
campagne puisqu'ils s'imaginent que la
campagne les gens ils se hissent
ressources tu vois ils sont à poil dans
les champs il se balade comme ça tu vas
à plat quand il voit impuissant lille
prennent ils sautent dessus lors d'une
pomme il l'a mangé tout s'est passé il
ya des préjugés inverse aussi les gens
de la campagne ont du mal à concevoir
qu'on puisse vivre à deux à paris dans
un mètre carré est payé 800 euros pour
ça
moi j'ai des origines mexicaines c'est
pour ça que je porte la moustache eux
en fait c'est du côté de ma mère et à la
moustache
non mais ma mère il s'appelle s'appelle
et bling mais avant elle s'appelait
carlos et moi j'ai découvert le mexique
avec erasmus ça ça vous parle bon j'ai
une petite définition 1 vaut ce qu'elle
vaut mais erasmus programme
international qui permet des étudiants
étrangers
fasciné par la france de venir étudier
chez nous il ya des étudiants français
fascinés par la fête d'aller dans des
pays où la vie est moins chère pour
picoler pour nick et moi j'y suis resté
sept ans il rencontre imprévue dans un
train qui les entraînent de paris à rome
charlotte une peintre reconnu se
retrouve face au grand philosophe
friedrich nietzsche nathalie connu on
est l'auteur elle est avec nous bonjour
mes amis les questions toutes simples
mais comment vous est venue l'idée de
transposer déjà le philosophe nietzsche
à notre époque
en fait déjà je suis passionné de cet
homme de sa vie de sa pensée de sa
philosophie
et puis en fait l'idée m'est venue en
partant en vacances dans un train je le
suis dit tiens pourquoi ne pas le faire
revivre à notre époque qui est une
époque compliqué je pense qu a besoin de
visionnaires et comme ça on était un
truc c'était une belle idée
de le faire revivre aujourd'hui vous le
découvrez très jeune vers l'âge de 14
ans qu'est ce qui explique un tel
attachement à tout ce qu'on fait je
pense que j'ai trouvé dans sa
philosophie beaucoup de choses qui me
correspondent
le grand oui à la vie déjà le
dépassement de soi
utiliser la souffrance au lieu d'essayer
de la nied pour en faire quelque chose
de positif et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
en a besoin aussi
en plus c'est quelqu'un qui vous touche
f1 qui me touche beaucoup qui a été
malade toute sa vie qui a lutté 4 sur
des passes et sa souffrance est un
exemple de si je pense à enliser il est
transposée à notre époque
qu'est-ce que vous avez dû adapter un
peu la pensée de cet homme dans
l'histoire pour qu'il s'intègre en fait
en fait nan parce qu'il disait lui-même
serait compris en l'an 2000 donc on y
est et en fait
je parle de sa vie et j'explique qu'il
est simplement parce que c'est pas le
but non plus du livre mais j'étais
obligé quand même de retracer sa vie et
sa façon de voir les choses en fait on
reconnaît souvent autour d'un si par
hasard à tous sera on ne connaît pas
toutes ces oeuvres
c'est aussi d'intégrer certaines de ses
oeuvres un peu moins connus entraient
d'une oeuvre à la fin mais non c'était
pas le but c'était vraiment de le faire
revivre dans une histoire d'amour
puisqu'il on n'en connaît pas sur lui ou
très peu en tout cas une non sais même
pas si j'ai un baiser ça n'a pas été
confirmée donc comme il aimait beaucoup
les femmes et pour lui les femmes
c'était la vie même et malgré qu'il ait
pas beaucoup écrit sur les femmes à peu
près 30 pages dans son oeuvre
donc j'avais envie de le faire revivre à
travers une histoire d'amour en fait un
amour on en parlait à tout petit peu
après mais ce qui est important c'est
dans cet ouvrage c'est que vous vous
nourrissez de l'actualité on parle
notamment des attentats et
l'omniprésence de larbin oui et puis en
fait si bon après il faut lire le livre
il fait partie travaille en fait pour le
gouvernement
en plus il était pro européen donc
défend beaucoup l'idée d'une autre
europe
et puis il lutte aussi contre la montée
l'extrême droite ce qui nous touche
beaucoup en ce moment depuis un certain
moment et ça n'a jamais été le cas
depuis 1930
donc en fait il va très bien parce que
lui il avait senti la montée de
l'extrême droite l'antisémitisme aller à
son époque donc il est très bien assis
en fait on doit notre époque aussi pour
ça et vous en révéler aussi un homme
assez secret voire un peu manipulateur à
la salle est déjà dans ses écrits je
pense que c'est et non je pense que
c'était
par exemple avec wagner qu'il adorait
même s'il a rompu avec lui son amitié
toute sa vie le regrettera mais pour des
raisons à wagner était antisémite il lui
défend des détails étaient contre
justement le fait d'être d'empyr etc
mais je pense qu'il a été capable par
moments oui 2
de faire un peu de langue de bois pour
se faire aimer mais finalement il a il
est retourné à sa volonté et à lui-même
en fait alors on a beaucoup parlé du
philosophe nietzsche mais il ya une
autre paire femme jeune et fort toute
l'histoire une femme accouche charlotte
peintre de talent qui connaît une
période difficile donc il dit à beaucoup
d'importance
bah il se découvre en fait l'un l'autre
sans le savoir vingt ans auparavant et
ils vont s'aimer sans se connaître à
travers leurs oeuvres leur philosophie
leur personnalité et cette femme qui est
une femme libre
ce que je défends beaucoup aussi dans
mes livres en général va connaître un
destin
qui va peut-être être un peu modifié à
cause de lui c'est ce qu'on va découvrir
dans le livre à travers aussi l'éditeur
de nietzsche qui est un personnage plein
de névrose effrayant mais j'étais ce
livre défend aussi beaucoup la liberté
des femmes aussi et chamboule aussi le
phénomène de couple de l'amour qu'on a
l'habitude vous en tout cas dans lequel
on a été conditionné quand même pas mal
et puis je pense sincèrement ce sont les
êtres libres et notamment les femmes qui
feront bouger les lignes et qui les font
déjà beaucoup bougé donc c'était
important de mettre en avant une femme
allait pas marié et n'a pas d'enfant qui
est pas dans un schéma classique et qui
malgré tout vit une passion une vie
pleine d amour
voilà enfin mais pas le schéma le modèle
classique on a l'habitude de voir et à
ce qu'elle dit il ya un peu de vous en
charge jusqu'à avant d'écrire vous
peignez est-ce que vous avez mis un peu
de vous même
il ya toujours un petit peu de dossiers
chauds avec je pense faire partie de
ceux de cette liberté en fait
d'expression de vie alors on a parlé de
philippe vite fait quel éditeur de
nietzsche très effrayant comme
personnage quand il rentre un peu dans
sa pensée la psychologie vous fascine
aussi alors la psychologie m'intéresse
beaucoup et je pense qu'on peut pas moi
je ne juge pas les gens justement parce
qu'on a tous une histoire et ça vient
soin de l'enfance et donc philippe dans
le livre à une enfance tous les trois
d'oeuvre une enfance compliquée et après
on se développe avec son environnement
sa personnalité les évitements etc donc
c'est un personnage trouble qui va
essayer de faire capoter cette rencontre
me vas t'y arrives et ça je voulais
juste qu'on parle aussi du bas de
l'amour du sentiment amoureux vous en
avez parlé c'est quand même un thème
qu'on retrouve dans vos entre ouvrage
oui ça vous passionne bassin de patience
ça me passionne et s'il ya ma vie parce
que j'ai connu aussi un divorce et un
changement de vie radical de par mon
histoire personnelle et puis après
d'autres formes d'amour journée vécu
plusieurs et en fait ça m'intéresse de
décortiquer l'amour et de toucher tous
les sentiments qu'on peut vivre et je le
fais à travers la poésie sensuelle
notamment qu' une expression libre aussi
qui permettent de dire beaucoup de
choses importantes sur ce sujet voilà
j'ai dit à leur faisait l'amour c'est
universel mais y'a pas moi j'essaie de
les conditionner l'amour en fait voilà
l'amour est multiple et plurielle et
c'est ça qui m'intéresse aussi
j'en ai dit quelques mots tout à l'heure
vous avez multicasquettes vous écrivez
vous êtes artiste tente mais vous êtes
aussi impliquées autour de l'enfance oui
si on peut finir la dass et cet
entretien ça tombe bien ce qu
aujourd'hui c'est la journée contre les
violences éducatives ordinaires et ça
fait un peu plus de dix ans que je
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes et la maltraitance faite aux
enfants qu'il ya un fléau qui détruit
des villes plus de 130 femmes qui
meurent chaque année on dit deux enfants
par semaine alors les suçons compliqué
parce qu'il ya pas de statistiques de
fait mais on compte pas non plus les
enfants qui sont décédés à la naissance
etc bref et il faut que tout le monde
s'y mettre et que le gouvernement aussi
s'y mettre sérieusement parce que pour
l'instant il ya beaucoup de mesures qui
sont pas mises en place et les enfants
c'est tout c'est la vie c'est une
priorité je pense et c'est un
investissement qu'on peut revoir
notamment sur votre site qui va
s'afficher en bas de l'écran
merci à nathalie fusil alors je le
rappelle le sujet principal c'était
votre ouvrage paris rome et nietzsche
rencontre charlotte
il est notamment distribués par hachette
livre et on passe maintenant à notre
page agenda
[Musique]
pour ce premier agenda une exposition
jusqu'au 24 mai colette base grande
taille vous transporte au japon cette
passionnée du pays du soleil levant
partagent une quarantaine de clichés qui
sont à découvrir à la galerie modern art
de versailles
c'est un des rendez vous incontournable
du printemps les grandes eaux et les
jardins musicaux ont rouvert au public
au début du mois d'avril un mois déjà
que le public peut profiter du spectacle
au château de versailles
mais pas d'inquiétude ce rendez-vous
court jusqu'au mois d'octobre et un
spectacle pour conclure ils s'aiment se
disputent se réconcilient des scènes de
vie en sketches et en chansons sexe fort
parents faible s'adresse aux parents
futurs parents au couple et c'est à
découvrir les 3 et 4 mai prochain à la
royale factory 2 versailles
c'est la fin de ce set une culture merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]